[Music]
on this Monday night containing the
contagion after two U.S bank failures
the reassurances to customers your
deposits will be there when you need
them and the calls for tighter
regulations I am absolutely shocked at
the swiftness of how the entire Fiasco
unfolded
turbulent times for Discount Airlines
right after flare planes were seized
what's the future of low-cost carriers
recognizing hockey history a
groundbreaking moment in the NHL 75
years ago today
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a Fallout from the
collapse of two American Banks and how
governments are doing all they can to
reassure other banking customers neither
Silicon Valley Bank in California nor
Signature Bank in New York were big and
both largely focused on business
customers with digital assets but there
is concern their demise could be
contagious at Silicon Valley Bank people
lined up today U.S banking Regulators
have assured depositors they will be
paid back in full and be able to access
their money to fund their businesses in
Canada the banking regulator has taken
temporary control of svb's only Canadian
subsidiary which lends to corporate
clients we'll get to what's behind the
collapse at these two banks in just a
moment but we begin with Jackson prosco
on how fears are being calmed
reassurance came just before the markets
opened all customers who had deposits in
these Banks can rest assured I want to
rest assured they'll be protected and
they'll have access to their money as of
today in a rare move the U.S government
announced it will backstop billions of
dollars in deposits at two failed
American Banks hoping to restore
confidence in the system and prevent a
run on banks Nationwide every American
should feel confident that their
deposits will be there if and when they
need them the stunning collapse of two
banks in three days has spread fear from
Wall Street to Main Street they were
entrusted with our money
and didn't do the job that they should
have done there were long lines of
customers outside branches of Silicon
Valley Bank in California and at New
York's Signature Bank which was
shuttered by Regulators Sunday if
there's any question I want to empty my
accounts and bring it to another bank
the rapid response from Washington sent
Jitters through the markets over fears
of a broader crisis shares of regional
Banks plummeted nervous investors worry
the smaller Banks may not be able to
back their deposits they kind of brought
out pretty overwhelming Force to try to
spill this before it gets out of hand I
mean it's important that the core of the
financial system is not subject to much
of this risk the very biggest banks
don't have these problems fear is the
contagion that most worries Washington
the White House is rushing to shore up
the banks insisting this is not a
taxpayer-funded bailout Deposit
Insurance fees will back the funds
analysts Believe the full impact of the
rapid collapse may not be understood for
weeks and other small Banks could still
be in Jeopardy part of restoring
confidence will involve getting to the
bottom of the second biggest bank
failure in U.S history there will all
but certainly be hearings and
investigations the White House suggests
there's also a need for tougher
regulation of the banking sector
Donna all right Jackson in Washington
thanks what's happened is a wake-up call
to Regulators everywhere in the UK
bankers and Regulators spent a hectic
weekend trying to avert huge losses in
the end HSBC agreed to buy Silicon
Valley Bank's UK operations for one
British pound in a deal that ensures
customer deposits are protected despite
that investors dumped European banking
stocks today sending shares spiraling
into their worst day in more than a year
and gaviola reports on what's behind all
this and the impact on Canada
Forbes listed Silicon Valley among the
best of America's banks for 2023 just
days before it collapsed I am absolutely
shocked at the swiftness of how the
entire Fiasco unfolded Rising interest
rates limited tech companies ability to
raise money forcing them to burn through
their cash and pull money out of svb on
March 8th to fund client redemptions SBB
sold 21 billion US dollars worth of
government bonds at a loss as they'd
plummeted in value when interest rates
climbed still strapped for cash svb
announced the sale of 2.25 billion U.S
in stock which sent its stock plummeting
a bank run ensued when too many
customers tried to withdraw their money
at the same time Tech financier John
Ruffalo analyzed how its collapse would
affect Canada and shared his findings
with Ottawa we were able to produce that
data over 48 hours which gave us the
necessary statistics to understand that
the impact in Canada was was quite low
our national banking regulator has
temporarily seized the assets of the
loan branch of svb in this country its
business in Canada primarily lending to
corporate clients and the branch doesn't
hold any commercial or individual
deposits it was a very sobering moment
for Tech c100 is a global community of
Canadians in Tech svb was a foundational
partner they would end up sponsoring
events they would provide funding to
organizations and not-for-profits such
as ours they brought a lot of
entrepreneurs together svb's demise
highlights the risk introduced in 2018
when then president Donald Trump rolled
back regulation put in place to ensure
the financial crisis wouldn't happen
again
the legislation I'm signing today rolls
back the crippling Dodd-Frank
regulations that a crushing Community
Banks
and Credit Unions Nationwide in the wake
of svb's implosion Bond markets are
dramatically repricing causing a rethink
of the bank of Canada's next moves many
investors now betting that our Central
Bank will cut rates by a quarter of a
percentage point at its April 12th
meeting Donna all right and gaviola in
Toronto thanks some breaking news out of
Quebec tonight two people are dead after
what police are calling a serious
accident involving a pickup truck and
several pedestrians it happened this
afternoon in the town of amqui in
eastern Quebec about 640 kilometers
Northeast of Montreal investigators say
a man in his 60s and a man in his 70s
were killed nine people are in the
hospital two of them with serious
injuries the driver of the pickup a
38-year-old man is being questioned by
police there's no word if this was an
intentional act investigators are
working together more information
a big win for a small City in
Southwestern Ontario Volkswagen
announced it's going to build its first
North American Electric Vehicle battery
plant in St Thomas Ontario VW is the
largest automaker in the world and both
the federal and provincial government
ministers are calling this a major vote
of confidence in Canada being a leader
in the EV supply chain Volkswagen
intends to start production in 2027 in
Saint Thomas no word yet on exactly how
many jobs will be created but it's
expected to be in the thousands and will
bring Auto jobs back to an area that
lost a Ford assembly plant a decade ago
Flair Airlines tried to reassure its
passengers today after an extraordinary
development on the weekend four of its
planes were seized because of overdue
payments it's casting doubt on the
future of the airline and on other
low-cost carriers in Canada Toria isri
reports
the delays may be over for the discount
Airline but the debacle is exacting a
heavy cost on its reputation if they're
going to not pay their bills and lose
some
some planes I'm sure that's going to put
an impact on who's going to book with
them from now on an American Leasing
Company seized four of Flair's planes
after the company fell behind on
payments almost 2 000 passengers were
affected right at the start of the March
break travel season I hope that Flair
does do well because it if it wasn't for
the prices we wouldn't have been able to
do this at all so
that's the way it is these days right
the airline admits it's facing
challenges but says it has rebooked or
reimbursed passengers this was uh
obviously unexpected and unusual and we
needed to play catch-up the
edmonton-based carrier initially blamed
maintenance issues until admitting it
was a commercial dispute we were about
one million dollars in arrears which is
about half of one day's sales for us so
it wasn't a big amount we didn't expect
this action but some Aviation experts
were expecting it pricing they were
charging was very aggressive in the
marketplace was that pricing too low uh
to cover off the cost of leasing these
airplanes the answer probably today is
yes Flair's recent financial troubles
are shaking consumer confidence and also
raising questions about the future of
discount carriers which have long
struggled in Canada there is more choice
in the low-cost Market than a decade ago
Flair Canada jet lines swoop play and
links which has just announced its
flying to Fredericton is there going to
be some consolidation here possibility
exists again most of these Ultra
low-cost carriers none of them are
publicly traded so they're not releasing
any Financial numbers WestJet has
acquired Sunwing after a tumultuous
holiday season that led to the
cancellation of all of its flights out
of Saskatchewan the airlines are
dividing the country up and getting to
be a problem no less choice and with
less Choice passengers worry Canadian
Air Travel will be more expensive and
unreliable terea isri Global News Ottawa
in the UK tens of thousands of Junior
doctors are on a three-day strike
British Medical Association says its
doctors are overworked and underpaid
while wait times and workloads have
reached record highs the walkout means
operations and appointments will be
canceled for thousands of patients and
Senior doctors have to cover Emergency
Services critical care and maternity
Services nurses and paramedics have also
staged strikes in recent months in the
UK demanding better pay and working
conditions
King Charles III took Center Stage for
one of his late mother's Signature
Events Commonwealth day and while
diversity and culture played a prominent
role in the day's annual service critics
say it does not wash away the realities
of the Commonwealth's Colonial history
our Europe bureau chief Crystal
gomancing Reports
happy birthday
a traditional Maori Haka performed for
King Charles III complete with a
traditional moment of touching noses
something he's done as Prince but not as
king the Commonwealth has been a
constant in my own life
and yet its diversity continues to amaze
and inspire me
56 Nations make up the Commonwealth it
evolved out of the British Empire though
the majority of member nations are now
independent it's near boundless
potential as a Force for good in the
world
demands our highest ambition the
Commonwealth
days to harm
an economic ties but because the king is
involved it does come with controversy
either there should be no head they
don't really need a head they've already
got other people in the leadership
positions we don't need to keep
highlighting this concept of bloodline
and Royal people
in 2018 heads of member states honored
the Queen's wish for Charles to head the
Commonwealth but it was stressed that it
was a non-hereditary role
demonstrators chanting not my king were
also present as were those highlighting
commonwealth countries that have
discriminatory practices despite the
group's Charter promoting tolerance
respect and religious freedom
like all events where a royal is present
the service drew a crowd of supporting
onlookers and that is one of the
intangibles offered to member states a
sense of community often seen on Royal
tours
Crystal gemancing Global News London
the BBC has reversed the suspension of
its highest paid personality Gary
lineker a soccer commentator was taken
off the air after he criticized the UK's
Asylum policy in a tweet last week
lineker tweeted that the policy which
aims to crack down on undocumented
migrants was immeasurably cruel and he
said the language used around it was not
dissimilar to that used by Germany in
the 30s the suspension caused
embarrassment for the BBC over the
weekend when other on-air personalities
pulled out of soccer coverage in
solidarity with lineker the director
General has apologized for the
disruption and announced an independent
review of the corporation's internal
social media guidelines
southern Africa hit hard for the second
time in a month coming up the deadly
damage from Cyclone Freddy plus
saturated state California braces for
more rain with Millions already under
flood alerts
another atmospheric river is on its way
to flood ravage California it's expected
to move in overnight and could bring
heavy rain snow and strong winds there's
already widespread flooding across the
state streets turned into rivers
stranding residents many of whom had to
be rescued the Central Coast has been
particularly hard hit a swollen River
breached a levee there inundating a
farming community over 18 million people
in California are now under flood alerts
tonight's storm will be the 11th
atmospheric River to hit that state
since December
in Malawi at least 66 people are dead
after tropical Cyclone Freddy ripped
through southern Africa for the second
time in a month torrential rains and
landslides are also swamping parts of
Malawi and Mozambique Cruisers sifting
through storm debris to look for dozens
of people who are still missing Freddie
is one of the strongest and longest
lasting storms ever recorded in the
southern hemisphere
now to the war in Ukraine Ukrainian
forces say they're still managing to
repel Russian troops in bakmut but it is
a grind the military senior Commander
says soldiers are using artillery and
tanks to keep Russian troops from
capturing the town it's the focal point
of fighting in eastern Ukraine Russia is
attacking from several directions but
has failed to close a ring around
Ukraine's defense Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski says his officials
believe 1100 Russians have died in less
than a week in bakmut
China Clipper ahead the push to
recognize one of hockey's Barrier
Breakers
[Music]
75 years ago today history was made on
the ice Chinese Canadian Larry Kwong
broke the color barrier to become the
first non-indigenous person of color to
play in the NHL he only played a single
one minute long shift for the New York
Rangers but as Heather York's West
explains his overall impact on the sport
is something his supporters say needs to
be recognized
and he would dream about one day playing
in the NHL decades before these students
were born Samantha heinz's grandfather
Larry Quang did something that had never
been done before in the third period he
got the chance to jump on the ice and
she wants to make sure this generation
knows all about it in a predominantly
white
sport you know we can we can kind of
share his story and talk about it and
let people know that he was there and he
he was ready to play but because of his
race they wouldn't let him I was really
proud and I was I said I finally made it
it was 75 years ago that Chinese
Canadian Larry Quang made his debut in
the NHL skating for just a single shift
with the New York Rangers but at the end
of that minute he stepped off the ice
leaving the game forever changed Larry
means so much to me my parents came to
Canada as refugees when you think about
him stepping on the ice whether it's
with the Rangers with the Rovers playing
at the Quebec Senior hockey league and
then eventually playing and coaching in
Europe he was breaking barriers
everywhere known as the China Clipper
Huang was a player of exceptional speed
and skill but he was never given another
chance in the league John belavil rated
him as a great hockey player Dickie
Moore said he could do it all Larry once
scored two goals on Jacques plant in 47
seconds he had grown up in the Chinese
Exclusion era and I think this was
a continuation of that exclusion there's
Larry right there but Chad soon doesn't
believe he should be excluded anymore
it's wise soon as among those
petitioning for Quang to be inducted
into Canada's Hockey Hall of Fame so
that his story as a barrier-breaking
builder of the sport can be permanently
recognized he went back down to the
trail Smoke Eaters at age 22 and back in
this classroom students who are just now
learning of quang's story agree I feel
like like a big story like this with
like the first Asian like hockey I feel
like it should be more well known and
I'm disappointed that it's like not 75
years after his historic achievement is
something Larry Quang supporters are
working hard to change Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is Fish Creek Provincial Park
in Calgary Alberta thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]